President Biden jetting off to vacation
as is Lackey so left to clean up yet
another huge mess in a classic holiday
news dump the administration releasing a
report giving Biden a free pass on his
disastrous withdrawal from Afghanistan
and blames it all on his predecessor of
course the president couldn't be
bothered to answer questions
Biden sent John Kirby out for an
embarrassing news conference while he
snuck away to Camp David for some RNR
the liberal media is furious after only
getting a 10-minute heads up on the
bombshell release and it looks there it
looks like they're having a hard time
spinning it
the word mistake appears once in this
12-page report National Security advisor
Jake Sullivan said they were going to do
a hot wash this 12-page document is a
whitewash there is it is narrative it is
light on specifics uh it's devoid of
citations there's considerable
frustration that some people at the
department think they're not being
honest the White House needs to take
responsibility for what happened in
August on its watch over which it had
control
the father of a marine killed in the
Kabul Airport attack agrees
you're the president of the United
States the buck stops with you it's your
responsibility stop making excuses
the full event Afghanistan has marked a
dramatic drop in Biden's support which
to this day has never recovered and now
a stunning 67 percent of Voters say
Biden doesn't deserve to be reelected
okay uh you know Jesse I'm going to
start with you the the truth is that his
numbers and we talked about this
yesterday have dropped they have never
recovered but when Kirby came out
yesterday he said that he was proud and
and there was one thing that that I
found very disturbing he said that he
was proud that they were able to get out
of a d uh a a defunct Airport
and I thought to myself you made the
decision to exit Afghanistan not out of
Bagram but out of a defunct Cosmopolitan
airport in the middle of four million
people
he's never had to answer that question
Joe Biden about Afghanistan if I ever
had him in the room I'd say why are you
proud of that disgraceful exit why'd you
check your watch when you were watching
the coffins come home at Dover but judge
he hasn't been asked anything the man is
terrified of reporters he triggers a
raid in Mar-A-Lago and then he leaves on
vacation he blames everything for Donald
Trump and then leaves on vacation covid
the border the Spy balloon everything's
Trump's fault if you could get the guy
in a alone in a room he would melt down
just simple questions he wouldn't be
able to answer these questions you said
you had no idea what was going on in
China but your family's getting Millions
from the country why'd you say that do
you have confidence in your vice
president
how many times can the guy just lie and
then leave I mean I would ask him this
um why'd you say the Chinese spy balloon
was a wasn't a major breach
and then they sucked up all of our
intelligence I mean what is your plan
for the Border do you think that women
should be able to play in men's sports
did the Keystone workers that you fired
ever find jobs building solar panels did
you ever make Jill Biden sleep on the
couch after she called Hispanics tacos
I'm just kidding about that but all the
other questions are legitimate questions
and the White House and the White House
Press Corps has this fraudulent
Arrangement where they allow the
president of the United States to never
answer a question and this why this guy
is a fraudulent president because if you
ever put me orbit bear alone in the room
with the president he would break down
why are you dragging bread into this
because he would never do an interview
with me
seriously you know Jillian one of the
things that that is true is that the
Press was upset about the fact that they
got the Afghan report 10 minutes before
the briefing as they saw the president's
leaving the White House to go to uh Camp
David you know you have been in this
world for a long time I mean even the
Press is upset in addition to a lot of
democrat congress people people in the
in the house and the Senate I think that
the problem judge with the report is
actually a lot
bigger and broader than the Optics
associated with yesterday which were
terrible like you mentioned reporters
getting this a couple minutes before the
briefing started so they had no time to
even read it before they were in front
of the press secretary
despite the fact it was also issued
basically as the president was leaving
for the weekend that's all
problematic but the bigger problem is
that this report was really a decoy it
was designed as a decoy what really
happened yesterday is that the defense
department
sent an after-action intelligence report
classified to the Senate and the house
committees that oversee defense issues
to explain their assessment of what
happened during this time when we
withdrew from Afghanistan because there
was no unclassified version available
yesterday to release to the American
people to release to the media the White
House drafted this 12-pager the National
Security Council wrote it and laid out
again the Biden administration's sort of
talking points their case which we don't
need to hear we have all heard it
seventeen thousand times since this
since the tragic events happened so
that's really what happened yesterday
with this report it was ill-conceived it
was ill-executed and then the timing
could not have been worse well you know
there is some sound that I'd like you to
listen to
um Lawrence on the Marine who told
lawmakers that the leaders ignored the
warnings of the imminent suicide bomb
her
over the communication Network we passed
that there was a Potential Threat and an
ID attack imminent
this was as serious as it could get
a requested engagement Authority while
my team leader was ready on the m110
semi-automatic sniper system the
response leadership did not have the
engagement Authority for us do not
engage plain and simple we were ignored
our expertise was disregarded no one was
held accountable for our safety
and the truth Lawrence is that the
families of the 13 service people who
were killed have never gotten any
answers and they still want answers
um I think the sad Point here is Kirby
the Admiral he knows better he knows
better he was in the Pentagon when they
were advising the White House that this
is a bad move this is going to be a
catastrophic it was also at the Pentagon
as is all good so all these stories and
tells
he already knows all of this this is him
being forced into a role Jesse calls her
binder because binder couldn't do this
press conference she wouldn't be able to
do it so they sent him out there and he
had to play covered the white house
instead of
what he knows from his experience being
there you can go through all the sound
from back when he was the spokesperson
for the Pentagon of him saying that it
was a disaster that they warned the
White House you can go to the testimony
there so then you're saying that Kirby
was not being honest with the Americans
he was totally lying there and I think
they did him a disservice by sending
them out there or did he do himself a
disservice by going well he answers to
the commander-in-chief but the
commander-in-chief won't answer to the
American people he sends his aides out
there to do it I think that's what we
should be upset about is the president
refusing yet again to answer questions
from the press and I I I think that the
Press is getting tired of it but then we
move on to the next Scandal and they let
him buy on that Scandal
um again they can't be the Press can't
be mad now because they allowed the god
to be in the basement the entire time
how many press uh uh live shots that I
do outside of Joe Biden's Delaware house
begging him to come out and talk to the
American people so again they can't be
bad mad now when they allowed the guy to
do this through an entire campaign and
now they're suddenly upset that he won't
speak now that he's the president of the
United States
um yeah he's doing what he got elected
doing presidents have spoken I just
dawned on me when Lawrence was talking
presidents have spoken from the White
House podium
when fewer Americans have died the
president could have spoken yesterday
himself directly yeah and and you know
Jessica the truth is that we left
Americans there Lincoln says that
several Americans remain detained by the
Taliban the Biden Administration admits
it left hundreds of Americans in
Afghanistan and we've had to have
Pineapple Express and not the American
Military help Americans out I mean the
whole thing is a disaster
I would not disagree with you I haven't
since it happened and there are a lot of
Democrats on record talking about it
especially combat veterans people who
were over there themselves and people
who for instance worked with these
incredible folks who risked their lives
to be interpreters for us to fight
alongside us and then their visas
couldn't be sped up fast enough and they
were left behind there's something
outrageous like an 18-year backlog to do
this
um
I think a lot about how
important and what a special class
veterans are in this country and they
should be in every country but they
deserve to be treated differently
because they're willing to sacrifice
their lives for us and that's something
that's emphasized in every
Administration how special these people
are and in thinking back to how
angry people were myself included that
President Trump wouldn't address
veterans who were angry with him about
mocking John McCain like a kazir Khan
type of person right and we said you
should always talk to these people
because if they've got something to say
they know more than we do about these
issues these people who are gold star
families Etc and I think that Joe Biden
owes these people that respect to talk
to them to face them to address the
American public about it and he did in a
speech say the buck stops with me about
those 13 service members who lost their
lives but this certainly was an
opportunity and I don't begrudge him
going to Camp David for Easter break
that that's a silly Samantha but it
wasn't for not answering the question
and also he has this weird thing that he
does and he did it when we lost the
third team that he took it back to Bo we
we have all lost family members at some
point in time but you don't get to
invoke your dead son to use it as cover
when you're addressing a travesty that
you cause yeah he does it all the time
he does it also anytime there is a
national tragedy he says I understand
because I lost the sun yeah no no you
don't understand you put their lives in
danger and I think that's what the
people want sometimes you got to take
the L as the commander-in-chief
and he hasn't been willing to do so and
it was a disservice to send Admiral
Kirby there who was there trying to
facilitate a lot of this stuff it would
have been a disservice to send Kareen
John Pierre even though she's the press
secretary go face the American people
yourself be a leader
he has trouble doing that hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else